[Music]
and um criminal Muse a stupid our
favorite Beatle Alice criminality said
you mean Alice is it yes good Alice
criminally malice news terminalis way
remember submitted by Gregg Gregg Gregg
Gregg we submit again possums idiot
robbers were arrested after the store
owner told them to come back later
okay just come back I'll have more money
later okay all right why are they high
that's the first question
that's a good question dad [ __ ] ball
honey imagine they go back to their lair
and they're like you know what nobody
told me they'd have 10,000 more dollars
when I come back later
I'm gonna be impressed of how dumb these
guys I might I'm already impressed
where was this address so this takes
place in Belgium and the owner he runs
in e-cigarette shop and so there were
these six armed individuals I walked in
his store around 3 p.m. that's one
person said that's crazy cuz Belgium you
don't think crying I think waffles
maybe that's why maybe like people are
so honest in Belgium that the criminals
were like okay that sounds even better
why wouldn't you think that there's any
crime yeah I think of crime in Belgium
it feels like a safe chocolate waffles
and french fries I think and those
Belgium dips we're like yeah doctor even
I feel like a lot of them like European
like - but but this is a straight arm
robbery like chocolate clouds and stuff
that's all huh Belgian yeah chocolates
and waffles yeah this drove through
Belgium
you know french fries were invented
there with real French they speak they
speak French and German but the main
thing is French and they are the way
they do their fries is always double fry
ourselves really crispy oh good
I like soggy fries yeah when you think
of European countries I think like
France does the art being UK with tight
black suits right yeah like it's like
high sophisticated stuff yeah the UK is
like I don't know like they're my soul
yeah they're like yeah they're like
minor yeah yeah my tax cut yeah Irish
guys are like the more aggressive like
don't bar fight their bar fights and
those but thank you for setting this
bookie yeah I wonder what Europeans
think of America other countries in
Europe because they're closer they
actually know like dial the real thing
will tell us in the comments yeah
tell us in the comments what the
Europeans think of each other they
really do know that's what they don't
get along yeah yeah maybe okay you know
how like we have like the white and
black conflict they have that with every
single other neighbor really the Irish
n-word the UK Android the Italian and
what the Greek they all did they can't
get along even more so because of all
servers like so much history to a ton
okay so anyway back to this these dumb
robbers so six yeah the owner said that
he's like I told them clearly that 3
p.m. is not the best time to hold up a
store you like you'll take a thousand
bucks now but if you come back tonight
you might be able to take more oh so
much sir so then that white person I was
thinking six arms I [ __ ] up yeah fix
our deal they came back later where you
think something had six eyes so then
that's when the owner called the police
and then but the police didn't think
that they'd return obviously yeah so
then at 5:30 the group returned Oh
and then once again you told the group
listen it's not closing time he's like I
berated them saying you have to buy a
watch
it's 5:30 not 6:30 send a bottle watch
it and they went fine you got a watch
yes we have people talk because I
pictured them as like the Swedish yeah
that's one of those like Muppets you
know Beverly chefs you know I'm talking
about yes yeah we have a Belgian robbers
like I don't know how you sound
I just don't know that's how he can't
speak yet cuz he's watching that [ __ ] in
the group left and then that's when the
owner called the police again he was
like hey look probably gonna be coming
back at 6:30 cuz no stupid there and so
they did come a third and that's what
I'm playing clothes policeman that we're
waiting for them and apprehended them
but the sixth so five they're like yo
that's man we trusted where are your
morals you lied to us
including a minor's all they say and
then the sixth one kinda wait oh he run
away I was like I thought he was like
but I'm on his I pictured them like
trying to rob them and he goes the Stars
I can't hear you you have to take your
ski mask off fine I said can you give me
money please and the camera like that
catches big yeah the owner was like they
are obviously not the brightest I feel
kind of bad though I feel like they're
so stupid like I'm like I'll let you
guys off but I'm gonna provide you with
like a simple job cuz you're dumb or go
to school that's so funny
I feel bad I've been like their first
robbery I hope so I mean yeah they
needed six Oh
so they feel like strong with numbers
and [ __ ]
yeah and now they go oh it's only $1,000
hey there's only six of us that's not a
lot of money guys let's come back later
mmm you know they actually did oh the
same day
that's so funny the same day I would've
been like oh thanks I'm gonna come back
later that's way more money [ __ ] man you
saved me a [ __ ] do you in a fell for
it if I was 13 and stupid
there was only one minors one that means
there was five people who are adults
I could make more children think about
that well what if he was super
convincing like wait wait don't don't
don't do all that Keys there homie no no
like the the storekeeper he was like no
no come back later come come back later
Julie smart you know I wouldn't think of
that yeah how pass yeah you have to come
in for them to be like oh wait let's
talk this out come back later they were
just kind of like hey can you have some
money you know well he was like
belittling that he was like you dummies
yeah when you rob a store and they're so
done that they go yeah we know that
we're just checking if you were here
three o'clock all right what's the
better time to come you just opened up
the shop there's no money in it yet oh
yeah we knew that funny I wonder what
the six ones up to he's like [ __ ] what
am I gonna do now thought all the homies
good that is a good diversion though
like if they come too early and you just
opened up you're like there's no
customers yet I don't have any money and
they might believe that they did believe
it yeah two times other people might
believe it too like I just opened up
shop cuz like you know only people that
know know that there's actually money in
a register for change I think no I think
if you knew that you just think what an
iPad or something you know I mean
something you can tell oh yes I just
tied that fool up and took his wallet
his license on my
just come back later when you have more
money I'll return these things that are
important to you and you take your car
keys oh yeah all right kidnapped the
[ __ ] and then call his wife but
most people are trying to grab it I'm
trying to work that hard they're trying
to just come back wait just yeah
grabbing and going oh man I love
watching us win store clerks fight back
video a little the little women this
dude fought somebody or three dudes with
a bomb like a big-ass bong it was like a
store where they sew like stuff like
that and you just see the video and then
you see the little puppy like running
away to hide and this guy's literally
like running him out of the store with a
big-ass bomb and they [ __ ] around
yeah I saw one where this guy he just
like basically gets comfortable with his
gun and he puts it away to help him grab
this thing out with him and as soon as
he put the gun away he turned around and
they started wrestling and then the
store clerk got the gun [ __ ] yeah and
then he was pointing at the guy and in
the robber ran and he locked the door he
hit himself because he got scared I saw
this one word this guy I think the guy
that the store owner obviously like has
some like gun experience cuz the other
guy he reaches back to pull his gun and
he immediately puts his hat and chops
his hand so when he pulled it he got
stuck and in the store owner pulled out
his gun oh and then he pull out his gun
and he made him put the other guy's gun
on the table and he just tell him to
leave oh this guy is like so gangster he
pull that your first put your gun here
i'ma pretend this didn't happen guys a
gangster ass mother yeah I wonder they
should have classes like that there are
classes oh yeah there's a ton of a
liquor store oh it's called like
disarming and like like everyday carry
my EDC the classes they have them like
everywhere sounds like a rave it is a
race okay but every day carry classes
they teach you like what is someone shot
up to the razor like way
[Laughter]
la carta paid for it thank God I'm like
hold on see like an Army Ranger kind of
guy they're just like what but they're
like I like your costume we're the bees
Avril have you guys ever been to one of
those no like a rave like an EDC thing
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah we have many many
skills and I would go dream in Mexico
really that's intense man if they had a
different music cuz you don't do drugs
well maybe I would have done drugs if
they had better music but the drugs help
you understand yeah yeah I didn't do
drugs no peer pressure TIFF I've never
caved in because if you don't do the
drugs you not understand the music yeah
and that's just too much time you got to
understand it it gets decoded yeah
it's a whole lifestyle - you gotta be in
it I'm too lazy for that and don't they
have like other styles of music now like
now they have like hip-hop how it is the
show up yeah if you go to like massives
and stuff but like if it's just because
the vibration and you're feeling it yeah
there's people that stand right in front
of the dugout because they're just like
oh my god
inside the speaker's yeah climb in I'm
not pictures inside of the speaker's
really and in the build-up goes doo doo
doo doo doo doo and then your body
starts feeling like it's becoming alive
dude dude and in the drop hits you feel
your body like yeah it's crazy it is
crazy okay
that explains it I'll do drugs don't do
it I'm not marketing it in a good way
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]